it's ten o'clock
okay
hello everyone
how's everybody doing
i'm still
i guess waiting for all the panelists to
arrive
i'm mark kaufman by the way hello
everyone how's everybody doing
i can see people letting us know where
you are which is great
kansas
um i'm here in vancouver in my basement
i assume people can hear me now let me
know if you can hear me and
florida quebec
new york city brazil
welcome
um
hang on a second and see if we can get
our
rest of our participants to show up
sorry for the
disturb earth
hmm
a few uh
technical
issues here but we'll get it sorted out
and get everybody here on the
on the call
keep letting us know where you're where
you're from
in the comments that's great
i'm not sure why
only my video is showing it seems like
our participants are there
um
let's see if i can
we may just need to
invite everybody again
well i must say i don't know why
we can't uh
oh i think we've
steve is showing up now although we
can't see his image
mute
and uh you know start video
there we are
okay yeah you have to promote me too we
can't hear you
oh can't hear all right let's see oh
yeah we can yeah we can
can you hear me now yeah yeah you don't
start video
here we are
okay yeah you had to promote me too we
can't hear you
oh can't hear all
right okay
we'll figure this out new tools
uh let's see i'll try and find uh eric
and jarine but uh in the meantime you
can go ahead
all right should i then start yeah there
seems to be a bit of a delay
so you might get the echo of what i'm
saying showing up in 30 seconds but
whatever let me just begin
i hope everyone can hear me
we're struggling a bit with the
technology
but
the purpose
is to create a place where we can
connect
because many of us are
isolating i'm self-isolating everyone
else here
and the link team is self-isolating so
we thought it would be a good idea on a
regular basis
to communicate and talk about our
favorite subject which is language
learning
uh of course we'll talk about link more
specifically but we want to talk about
everything that relates to language
learning
and we have four panelists today and
we're gonna go in the order that i see
them on the screen so i'm going to
you know yield the microphone to mark
and so he's going to start this off and
then he's going to hand it over to
dareen and she will hand it over to eric
oh the order has changed now so we might
it's up to mark however he wants to do
it and then i'll come back at the end
and share with you some of my thoughts
so thank you for joining us and i now
hand it on to mark who is our
ceo
executive commander-in-chief
at
link
thank you very much
hopefully that doesn't encourage a slew
of
uh new uh feature suggestions
um
yeah thanks very much for joining us um
as steve said we're all self-isolating
so what better thing to do than
talk about languages and and what i
thought uh uh what we're thinking is is
that we could just uh
show what we how we use link because
that's a question that comes up a lot
um
in support emails
on youtube youtube questions everywhere
so
um i think if we each spent five minutes
showing how we use link and then people
have a chance to ask questions i think
it might be interesting
so
i will start right now i'm studying
japanese
uh what i thought i would do is
uh show you how
i i import from netflix because i would
say that
um
most of the content that i'm studying
now i i think essentially falls into
three categories
uh
i still
use the mini stories and
go back and forth between the mini
stories and the other content that i'm
using
um and then i would say i use the
japanese link podcast because that's a
good source of um
natural content and and uh because it's
kind of casual conversation
uh the vocabulary level is is
uh not too difficult and there are
a lot of the words get repeated
um
it just seems to be easy conversation
every once in a while and you can see
here on the page well for those of you
who don't
read japanese it's more difficult but
um
i also do some news articles the news
articles are by far the most vocabulary
dense
lots of words that you that i'm looking
up the whole time so
i definitely want to mix those in or mix
the the
not just the mini stories but the
japanese link the casual podcasts i find
great intermediate content and then the
and then i i'm i am
using some netflix shows so this item at
the top samurai gourmet
is a netflix show
and so here is an episode that i haven't
yet imported
um are you sharing your stream because i
don't want you i should i should share
my screen
hang on a second
let's just share this here okay
so
hopefully you can
maybe it won't play if the whoops
oh
so
i'll pause that there because of the
webinar software isn't showing the
picture but that's okay
so
i have this show on netflix i'm going to
click our extension here
um
change the language
japanese
choose my course
import that lesson
and then i can open that lesson and then
here i am
looking at the lesson this is kind of an
interesting show it's
it's this retired japanese
guy that just retired who
basically every episode involves him
somehow ending up at some kind of a
traditional japanese eatery
lots of close-ups of the different
japanese dishes and the guy is so
excited about every
dish it's actually
kind of funny
and
the the the dialogue is relatively
simple too so that um
it's it's you can move through it
relatively easily the show episodes are
short so i i'm actually kind of enjoying
it even though it's kind of a weird show
but
it's interesting
anyway so so yeah i just uh i think uh
anyone who hasn't tried the netflix
import i i uh i am enjoying it i'm
finding uh the the um
japanese i'm doing japanese now the
shows are a little a little different
which
is to be expected i guess i i did i did
some spanish shows before which i found
really good too
um so i'm enjoying that uh
and then obviously using link if i'm
using it i tend to um
a lot of the time i would do it on
my mobile but here on the web if i'm
using the web i use the keyboard
make sure if you're using the web
keyboard shortcuts here
get to know them because they're they
make using the um
web version much much better
um
and then otherwise i tend to go for uh
hints with
without a lot of extra garbage like i
don't want the hiragana i don't want
long i want short so i'll take that
middle one
um
yeah and so i'll just move through it
like this
i tend to um if i see uh if i see uh
yellow word that i know i'm gonna make
it known
so that i can
get rid of my yellow words
um
and then essentially that's what i do i
go through i don't do much review i
review just by seeing the yellow words
in context
uh and clicking on them if i don't know
what they mean if i do know what they
mean i move them to know
um
so that gives you a bit of an idea i
think i'll i'll stop there
if you have any questions
uh about what i do please post them now
happy to answer them before we move on
to
uh
eric
and and just to say you can you can post
uh questions here here on zoom or you
can post questions on youtube
uh
somebody asked am i able to see other
members netflix uploaded content the
answer is no
anything you import is for you only
imports are private the only time
they're not private is if you
deliberately
uh share them and there you are prompted
to make sure that
the content is copyright free and that
you have
there are certain conditions that you
need netflix content has no audio so you
couldn't
share it even if you wanted to
um
that that goes for any kind of content
books netflix whatever you can import
anything you want and that is a question
that comes up quite a bit you can import
anything you want into your own account
without worrying about copyright because
it's it's just for you
[Music]
somebody says i don't know how to import
netflix
you just
go to netflix and and make sure you
install our browser extension so we have
a browser extension for
uh safari chrome and firefox you would
have seen me click on it just now so you
just have to
go you can actually find a link
to all the browser extensions
inside
link itself
i can i can show you that now actually
just to make it easy
uh
here in the sidebar
you can find all of our extensions
and all of our social media and mobile
app links
i have trouble finding foreign language
on netflix
yeah i mean i think netflix has
different
titles in different markets
um
i think i i don't know maybe someone
else can can suggest an easy way to find
foreign language content i feel like uh
there's a foreign language section i
don't know eric uh is there any or or
i i seem to just i haven't had no
trouble around you find it
well i mean i was finding turkish and
arabic movies so i can only assume that
italian german chinese russian is going
to be easier to find
i just you know searched for them and i
found them yeah i think so you just
search around you'll you'll find them
and sometimes
you think they're not german because
they're dubbed or
whatever language
uh but
the the the line you can just change the
the language like you can always hear
the original language you might have to
play around with your settings
uh i imported one
oh oh it's hard when it imported one
podcast but i could only see it if i
subscribed to it i did that but still
couldn't access it
yeah i'm not sure what that means
exactly if but if you
uh
i'm not sure what that question is to be
honest
um
uh
yeah
any questions on on youtube maybe i
could have you know having had a lot of
experience at importing and downloading
and importing podcasts there's a lot of
playing around and each podcast may be
different and have different
restrictions and of course without
getting permission from the podcaster
you can't share it but it's just a
matter of trial and error some work and
some don't
and with regard to podcasts
rarely do you get the transcript and
audio together so sometimes you try to
import the audio and then you have to go
find the transcript maybe it's on a
different page or
if it exists podcasts can can be
trickier when you're importing uh maybe
it may take a little bit more effort and
may take a little more searching to find
podcasts that actually come with a
transcript
uh someone asked can you import the
whole episode of its long yes you can if
the episode's too long uh it'll get
split into parts
but
there is a max length but it has to be
very long to exceed our maximum length
like hours
okay
now there was someone saying show how to
import from netflix but i see that eric
put up a link here here's how to import
netflix plus i just yeah plus i just i
just did it so if you can this this uh
live stream will be will be available so
you can you can watch it again later but
i i that's exactly what i just showed
uh
five minutes ago here
okay
okay
well maybe uh with that eric why don't
uh you're up next
all right can everyone hear me
is everyone oh yeah we can hear you okay
all right let me see how i do this um
okay so uh yeah i'm also
uh studying japanese as well um
and using some of the sources that mark
mentioned i don't use netflix i don't
really have an account on my computer
but there's a lot of other stuff that
i've been looking at and
some of you might see the videos i've
been posting on the link youtube channel
um in case you haven't seen those um i
would check them out after
dream and i have been sharing our
kind of uh
guides on how we're learning french and
japanese and i did a we do episodes
every week so
uh afterwards i'll share a link
um but um i can share my screen here so
let's see here
i'm gonna share my screen and on desktop
all right i guess my screen's being
shared now
all right i can only assume
okay so let me go to my link account
oh and by the way if you're still
wondering about netflix and uh how to
import those shows in the link there's a
youtube guide you just search
language learning with netflix and link
okay so
all right so here's my um
link account
and this is my japanese link
content
so
yeah my lesson so what i guess people
are wondering what i've been uh studying
so let's start with youtube
so with um
link you can import youtube videos as
some of you probably know
and the trick is for me to find youtube
videos with
um
captions closed captions that are
actually human
uh made so what i mean by that is
let me open this one this is a video
from a youtuber miku real japanese
so i'm just gonna open this uh
one of these uh lessons
just takes a little bit to load
okay so
actually let me if you see the youtube
video
and you click closed captions so let me
open this youtube video
okay so
here's the video and
so what i'd look for is
all videos that you import into link
have to have closed captioning because
that's where the text come from so
if you click that
or you click the settings bar
um you can see subtitles and then you
can see there's auto generated but if it
doesn't have auto generated beside it
you can just click
the japanese or the english and you can
see that the closed captionings follow
the dialogue there's no mistakes they're
correct because miku has put them in
and then you just click the import
extension up here
and then you click import
and then you'll open it up in link and
you'll be able to go through it so
once you import it it'll look like this
and then you can just go through it so
i've been going through
videos for the last while and they help
because you get the audio and you get
the transcript so you get both the best
of both worlds and reading and listening
to this kind of content is a little bit
different than reading books or
uh news articles because
it's actual native natural speech so you
get these little like
nuances that you wouldn't pick up in uh
in an article uh
say and then you can also like if you
are going through the
content you can click on the audio here
and you can also click on the speaker so
this is actually really cool because
when you pull in the audio from youtube
or other sources
link creates tran uh timestamps so the
audio should match most of the time
sometimes it's a couple seconds off but
most of the time this speaker
icon uh microphone icon should match the
sentence here
so they're laughing but
but as you can see you can match it from
there
and this is in sentence mode so you can
only do that in sentence mode which is
this thing here
so i've been doing that with a bunch of
youtube channels and as i mentioned in
the link youtube channel i go over some
other youtube channels that i've been
importing into link that have content
and
sorry uh natural closed captions
and then i'll quickly go over
showing you other content so
i do the same with anime
um this is from
a website called animeland and you can
import uh anime just as you would uh
like with youtube you can do it with
anime
um
there's no video in this case but you
still get the uh text and you still get
the audio
um so for those who know animeland.com
and use link
i definitely recommend trying to import
content episodes anime from there
and once again this is sentence mode and
i can play the sentence as i'm reading
the uh sentence as well
so it's really it's really awesome
because you're you're maximizing your
input you're getting the audio and
you're getting the uh you're you're
understanding how to read it so that's
probably my in my opinion the best way
um
to uh grow your vocabulary and your
comprehension
um
and then yeah also i've been doing lots
of tutoring
so just quickly show you this um
here are japanese tutors
and i've been doing tons of lessons with
japanese tutors
if you want to book a tutor on link you
have to just go to the tutor section and
it's only on desktop not on the mobile
and you just pick a tutor here
choose a time so let's say 30 minutes
and then you just look at the schedule
and you pick a slot that's that you can
do it so you just
click a shot reserve time
book conversation
and then you'll get a confirmation from
the tutor
so there you go i booked
a new tutor and you can see your
bookings in the my activities tab
and after that they send you a report so
when they send you a report you can
import that report into link
and as you can see here are all my
conversation reports with my tutors
i got tons and so
um
there and then it's like a lesson but
they just um
they're based on the conversation you
had so super helpful
um and that's pretty much it so i've
been focusing on lots of youtube
uh videos lots of anime and lots of
speaking with the
tutors on link to improve my japanese um
and as i mentioned on the uh youtube
channel uh the link youtube channel you
can find
uh a bunch of stuff that i've been uh
doing as well um
here is an example so this is
what it looks like
i just made this video but this is my
mobile ver the mobile version of my
content on link
so you can always check that out i show
you how to import on mobile
and go through the lessons on mobile as
well
uh yeah i think that's uh
that's pretty much
the rundown there's obviously a lot more
i can talk about but i think those are
the main points
um that i wanted to share
so i'll uh let's see uh
we got any questions yeah anyone have
questions
questions questions let me see if i can
find some uh i see that someone's been
trying to import ultraviolet a polish
detective show
when i hit import it says no text found
one thing there
netflix does and really all video
channels do seem to or or or websites
seem to change things periodically so
our extension periodically needs to be
updated
uh there was uh
there were some issues with netflix but
if you're using the latest
extension they should be resolved
uh if you're still having if you're sure
you're using the latest version
whichever whichever extension you're
using chrome safari or firefox
uh if you're sure you're using the
latest version and it's still not you're
still getting that error then let us
know
and we'll take a look and figure out why
that's happening and probably have to
update the extension again
uh someone's asking eric do you still
have your phone
uh attached someone's asking how to
import from mobile that'd be a good
thing to show
okay um let me share screen here
i don't have it attached but i have a
video so i can just do it
doing uh showing that video so oh then
just link that video maybe if it's
yeah i did i shared the video so you can
check that video
uh someone and maybe
someone's asking how about the kanji how
are you studying them these are
questions from from youtube
that was yeah how are you studying them
eric
um
i am reading like there's basically
almost two ways you can study kanji is a
through context or individual and i'm
kind of doing a bit like 70 in context
so
just lots of reading and then
the other 30 i might uh
uh do them individually by writing them
by hand and doing like kind of a flash
card but 75 percent i'm reading over and
over and over again because i prefer to
learn them in context
and i would say the same uh and because
that question i think came up when i was
speaking but
um there was a time where i tried to
to learn the kanji on their own and i
did learn some
but now i don't um
i don't do any dedicated kanji study at
all i just uh read and click on create
links
and the words that matter and the
characters that matter
reoccur more frequently and and you just
start to recognize them and
it's amazing actually how you just
recognize them even
ones that you know you haven't seen in a
while because i i i studied japanese
maybe 15 years ago then didn't study it
for
14 years and then started again and i i
was amazed at how some of the
words i was able to remember
so i think it's just a matter of
creating links and and doing what we do
it's no different than learning words
you're learning
kanji and words at the same time and and
your brain your brain will learn i don't
know if steve has anything to add there
yeah i was going to get into that
when i uh
opened my time slot because i also had a
question from someone who's learning
russian and asked if he can learn
russian grammar simply by listening and
reading so i want to get into that whole
subject but i'll save that for when i
speak okay okay
uh there just were a few other questions
i found in youtube so maybe we'll just
go through them quickly before uh jareen
can
move on to her segment
uh someone else what level do you need
to be at to read news articles in a
language
uh steve maybe you're i think you need
to be at the
i mean i like to divide it into six
levels call it the european framework
call it
you know you know beginner intermediate
and advanced so intermediate
high intermediate like level two
intermediate and that's why i was going
to get into this but mark mentioned and
eric that where you have this more
casual conversation type of content it's
not as uh vocabulary dense
and therefore it it bridges from that
beginner up to a level of say call it
intermediate 2
where you can you know happily read
newspapers i mean you can fight your way
through newspaper articles but when
there's 40
30
unknown words
it's tough and i'll also caution you
newspapers are easier than literature so
newspapers are tougher than natural
dialogues so it's a matter of having a
strategy so that you're not
you're with interesting content but
you're not creating too much pressure on
yourself fighting with a high percentage
of new words
there's another question here any plans
for a ui revamp
actually yes
we do have plans uh in fact we have a
major revamp underway right now
uh on all platforms so we're hoping
to
uh uh
release it
you know within a couple months
let's say we don't want to pin ourselves
down to any timelines but um
we are hoping i mean we're
partially testing it now and and
building it out so
major changes coming
uh improvements coming
yeah yes the answer is yes
um
and then someone else
which steve touched on there what is
your approach when it comes to everyday
language more colloquial and less formal
well maybe i could take two i see
another question here as well no my
approach in learning languages is to
stay neutral
because colloquial language
is it's one thing to understand it but
to try to use it before you have a good
sense of how it's used is very tricky
so
you can be in a more formal situation
and sound informal so i i am not that
keen on learning slang and
tremendously colloquial things when i
start into a language and then
eventually if i get enough exposure
i will start imitating those you know
that more colloquial way of speaking uh
also someone mentioned that they love
grammar and i'll get that into that when
i talk if you love grammar do grammar so
there's there's no
language learning is a personal journey
but i'll give you my personal journey
and where what i see as the role of
grammar when i speak
any advice of 72 languages at once
i'll get on to that too okay
hello
yeah okay so
um
yeah i think that's good then maybe with
that uh
darine are you uh
ready to go so you're ready to go
awesome
can you hear me everybody yeah
okay good
um so i'm currently studying french and
like eric i'm making a video each week
on the link channel
so um you guys can check those out if
you're also studying french and looking
for
content i like to share the
podcasts and tv shows and whatever else
that i've found there
um so i'll take you through i'm i'm at
i'm bridging the kind of beginner to
intermediate
phase right now
um so
i mean i should be doing a lot of
repetition with my studies but i'm not
i just read what i like right now i
really do need to do more of that but um
i guess i'm in a kind of a tricky
spot because i can't freely listen um
without really
reading the transcript of a podcast or a
tv show i'm using subtitles and don't
understand a great deal but enjoying it
and words and phrases are jumping out at
me more and more
which is exciting but uh
yeah so i'm very much a
beginner
about to be hopefully intermediate so
i've just got i just hit the 4 000 words
mark on uh on link
so why don't i share my
screen
one second
you guys will have to let me know
if you can see it
then you have to
allow it hold on sorry guys
are you guys able to see my screen yes
oh good
uh okay so
so i'm in the library right now the
things i'm doing to motivate myself
because i am at that beginner phase i
definitely am motivated by the streak
and color of the apple which i just
i was just demotivated to read from
silver which i'm quite upset about but
it's because um a lot of the listening
that i've been doing lately has been uh
through just watching tv shows on
netflix
um
so i don't uh get that time i add the
time to like afterwards but i don't uh
build i don't get the coins so apple
isn't doing so well it's not terrible
but it could be worse
um
but yeah i haven't yet tried uh
creating a lesson with a netflix show
transcript i will
do that soon i just think maybe that'll
be a bit difficult for me so right now
i'm just enjoying zomblanch and le
chalet two great french shows on netflix
if you guys are looking for kind of
spooky mysterious
thriller slash horror shows there's some
great ones
uh another thing i do to motivate myself
is i'm
part of the 90 day
hardcore french challenge so this one i
started in january so i'm actually about
to
it's about to finish and
you can see the targets there i'm shy of
the listening target i still have some
time but um that's always
something i think as a beginner you
struggle with to meet your listening
targets so um
i will
fill that but uh right now
right now it's um
it's not looking so good
uh also
in terms of
what i'm studying right now so i like to
uh i have some podcasts that i enjoy
that in a french podcast is one and the
balad podcast is another one this uh the
inner french podcast with hugo is
still running and he's creating episodes
weekly and he has a youtube channel uh
he's it's excellent excellent content
this uh my other favorite podcast the
ballad podcast has finished but we have
50 episodes in the uh the link library
so
can i just say one thing i noticed that
there has six 661
thumbs up or likes that's a good
indication of uh how popular or how good
a particular content item is i always
look for how many likes it's got yeah
that's very true that's very true she's
excellent and she has such a lovely
voice and um she takes you she's a half
swiss half french
woman she takes uh she takes you on
trips she went on as a child and and
still goes on she lives in switzerland
and often visits france
so yeah really just really interesting
interesting content so
uh so yeah podcasts i try to do an
episode a day
usually earlier on in the day then in
the evening i will read
a news article or two
um
what i do i just go to the
uh
the news feed
and i like to
i'm a little lazy maybe at night you
know you don't have so much energy so
i'll often just check out the article
and then if it's
short
i will import it um because i know i can
i can get it done
uh if it's a longer article i probably
will not
i'll just find
something a little shorter
uh so yeah
news articles at night a podcast episode
uh earlier on in the day and then as i
said i'm using netflix
i'm i have the subtitles on
it's not as good as listening on link
and having the transcript there for you
to save the words and phrases but
um as steve always says you know if you
have the language around you
it becomes more comfortable you start to
hear more things start to jump onto you
i didn't i haven't learned another
language yet um i know a little japanese
but
i never got conversational so i wasn't
really sure if that was true
i thought well maybe it's true for you
steve but is it is it really true for
the
your average person but yeah actually
i'm finding definitely i listen every
day without fail and i am words and
phrases of jumping out of me i repeat
them when i hear them because i'm so
happy that i actually heard them and it
doesn't just sound like a jumble of
noise so
um that's that's a really exciting
development for me um but yeah mostly
for me it's it's podcast episodes right
now uh trying to bridge that gap between
beginner and intermediate some youtube
videos i found and i mentioned these on
my um
weekly youtube video i found lots of
great youtube videos in french
with um
subtitles in french so you can make
lessons online but they're just a little
tough for me and i find it i get
frustrated so i i have them
ready to go but um i'm just trying to
get to a place where i can comfortably
watch and read on them right now so
um
yeah i think that's about it i've
started reading the petty france i want
to
then i think read steve your book in
french because i haven't actually read
it in english yet so i'm doing that one
in french i know it's in the library
um and then from there
find uh any book
maybe like a book i've read before
stephen king or something
um yeah
so that's that's what i'm doing on link
right now
if you guys have any questions french
learners non-functionalist beginners
like me who are trying to
bridge that gap between beginner and
intermediates
uh
there was a question here
somebody i learned german at
gcse
school qualification i love learning
grammar but i've been told grammar isn't
all that helpful at the start am i an
anomaly here
so he did sorry so they're gonna need a
german gcse
and is now studying grammar loved
learning grammar i love learning grammar
that has been told that grammar isn't
all that helpful and and i
i don't know
steve you can answer this question
yeah
okay well maybe then i could just lead
into
my or you can answer when you you speak
we'll see if there's any questions uh
specific to
jareen but i uh
when you when you watch on netflix do
you keep the subtitles on in english or
french
oh definitely english if i had
the subtitles i just can't i'm not
anywhere near being able to do that
unfortunately so
you have the subtitles on in english
okay
do you uh uh i mean yeah it depends on
your level very much i i think when i'm
in netflix i try to have the
the captions on so i try to read it
first on link then i watch it with the
captions on so that i can make sure i
i i understand what they're saying i may
not be 100 on the meaning but i i'm just
trying to make sure i understand what
their
what they're saying and hopefully if it
if i get lost i go back to link to
review what they actually said
but uh i think
sounds like a really good system way of
doing it yeah i'm just i'm
i'm a little lazy i just it's my tv time
so i just throw it on
yeah you can do both i find if the
captions are on then i get very lazy
with trying to understand uh yes
language
but uh everybody
is different i mean you to do what what
you
how you do it how you do it
um
how do i improve my listening skills by
using link
just be consistent i'm finding is the
most important thing too
um and like i say i'm listening and
reading um
subtitles in english it's not it's
nowhere near as helpful as
listening and reading along to the
french object yeah listening and reading
along is really helpful at the beginning
if you can't understand what they're
saying
listen while while trying to read and it
makes it makes a big difference and then
after a while
you you just get better but you need to
listen a lot like listening for five
minutes
isn't enough you know 30 40 minutes
every day
you know spend
10 15 minutes 20 minutes listening and
reading along and then go listen without
reading along and and just over time
your brain will make sense of it but
most people simply don't do enough
listening like
that if you listen to the dialogue one
time
and then
don't do any anything for the rest of
the day that's not enough
you need to you need to listen a lot
i find one thing i find helpful is i
listen to a you a podcast episode while
reading along you know say words and
phrases and then i'll go off and do
something in the car or wherever else
and listen to it um
just just listen to it i find that
really helpful because it's so fresh
or you feel like you're progressing a
lot because you you just read it and
listen so you you understand more than
you would if you if you were to listen
that night or the next day so i found
that very motivating um
and then you listen twice instead of
just listening once
i find that too for sure here's a guy
i'm a native spanish speaker who has
trouble with different regional accents
mainly from the uk
yeah so so do i
[Laughter]
they got they have a lot of
strange accents in the uk that take a
while to to get used to even as a native
speaker
uh of english
uh maybe if you're
from the uk you can understand them
yeah well yeah
you grow up with all these accents you
you understand that but there are some
people yes still like some really strong
northern and scottish accents wow
i don't know yeah
okay well maybe with that steve
why don't you give us uh take over
okay before i i share my screen
uh i thought i'd might touch on some of
the things that came up i see some of
the questions here too one that came
earlier
one of our viewers here
said
um i'm trying to learn russian and will
a russian grammar just come to me just
through a lot of input and reading and
this is kind of core
to our whole method
probably you'll want to look up can you
hear me you look as if you're yeah yeah
yeah so i i find that the grammar sticks
best when we're curious
so if we are given
a grammar explanation about something
that we haven't really noticed in the
language yet trying to explain things
that
are in the language but we haven't
experienced it i find that difficult to
absorb on the other hand if we have
through a lot of repetitive listening to
simple material like the many stories
we've come across certain structures in
the language we are now curious why does
it work that way and then of course we
can look it up we can google verbs nouns
and russian you know adjectives we can
see the declension tables we can look at
them we forget them it doesn't matter so
i think the grammar you will inevitably
through a lot of listening and reading
get a sense of the language but you'll
also be curious about certain things in
the language and at that time i think
it's a good idea
you may find that it's necessary to have
a look at the grammar even though if you
don't remember what's written there and
then you go back to your listening and
reading and there's a gradual process
whereby the brain gets used to how the
language works
so that would be you know one thing and
i also wanted to touch on
this idea of natural speech dialogues
podcasts
and i'll show in my persian some of the
kind of natural dialogues that we're
developing for persian this is good
intermediate content to get you from say
the many stories with lots of repetition
to more demanding difficult content it's
not as dense in terms of vocabulary it's
casual it's pleasant to listen to
so um that's kind of as a general
introduction
and now i will share my screen and show
you
what i am doing
in persian
so i'm assuming that you can see me see
my screen now
and
so bear in mind that i'm doing both
persian and arabic i was attempting
turkish at the same time but i gave up
on that because it's just too much and
this way i can focus in on the persian
and arabic they share this essentially
the same writing system
and it takes a long time to get used to
a new writing system even though
you may know in theory how hangul works
or how you know the cyrillic alphabet
works or the greek alphabet or the
arabic alphabet
for the brain actually to get used to
reading things in that alphabet takes a
long time so i decided to focus all my
reading on reading in the arabic
alphabet which means arabic and persian
so if i look at my uh what i have in my
lessons here
the mini stories has been my major
emphasis and
it is surprise i mean not surprising but
when i started these stories were just
noise struggling with a strange writing
system sounds that were just noise to me
and now i understand all 60 mini stories
but of course i have listened to them 30
or 40 times i've read it i don't know
how many times and i occasionally go
back there just as practice
and i'll just digress a bit i had to do
a
skype interview in korean
to refresh my korean i went back to the
mini stories in korea i went through all
60 mini stories to me the many stories
are a place for the beginner to get
started but it's also like a permanent
work area like a gym so every so often
you go back there
and it's the most common structures in
the language it's the most common verbs
in the language it ramps you up for
speaking
it gives you momentum
and you can and i personally find i am
able to listen to them over and over
again there's something about them i'm
able to listen to them and every time i
listen i discover something new so
that's all part of getting the brain
used to the language however in terms of
interest
here
uh now i do have as eric pointed out i
have all my conversation reports going
back to when i was i was doing a fair
amount of talking online because i had a
three-month sort of
challenge
in persian at the end of which i had to
do a video in persian so if you want to
speak you have to speak a lot so i was
doing a lot of online lessons with
tutors they would typically as with
eric they send me a report 15 or so
words and phrases they would record them
for me these become lessons and i have
now a historical record over a period of
three months or longer of my various
conversations with my tutor and i
occasionally go back there as well
now
we
i have a collaborator in iran
a lovely lady i've never met her but
she's traveled in india and she has all
kinds of interesting
stories that she tells
and as well as we had another group of
people but in particular uh sahara she
tells these stories
and then
she creates these circling questions for
each story
so the circling questions is like the
questions we have in the mini stories
where essentially
um
a statement is taken out of the main
content
and uh you know and then
so she talks for example she described
different
scenery in iran and then she has
circling questions
uh and so i find that very useful
because very often the the main story is
too difficult if you get the circling
questions you get bits and pieces of the
vocabulary then i go back into the main
story and i find that i'm able to
understand the main story better
now
one other thing i would say with regard
to comprehension
i recently did a video on
listening comprehension questions i'm
very much opposed to listening
comprehension questions because
if you listen to something or read it if
you understand nothing of course that's
no good you're not benefiting but if you
understand 40
or 50
that's good what matters is the 50 you
understood not the 50 you didn't
understand because the 50 you understood
is meaningful content that is meaningful
exposure getting your brain used to the
language so to be asked a bunch of
questions that demonstrate that you
didn't understand 30 40 50
to me is meaningless you need to and and
i will move on uh when i understand 40
50 60 i move on to the next and the next
and the next to get something new
because i can't keep on listening to the
same story and not understanding the
same parts of the story after a while
i'm not doing anything i'm better off
bearing in mind that i always mention
manfred spitzer repetition and novelty
you have to give your brain novelty you
can't just do repetition all the time so
uh
to that extent comprehension don't be
worried if you don't understand it all
don't wait until you've totally nailed
down one story you're actually
you're slowing down your learning you
want to be expanding to other stuff
where you will also only understand 50
but eventually
that content that three months ago you
only understood 50 of you'll now be up
to 70 as if by magic because a lot of
those words and phrases you will
encounter them elsewhere
also in my
persian learning
sahara was also able to get permission
from this
persian podcaster who i gather is
located in norway
and puts out sort of summaries of
various self-help books most of them are
written in english
sahara goes in got permission for us to
share them
goes in
and divides them up into six seven eight
minutes segments and then creates
circling questions for each of these
segments so i point this out because
it's an example of how today
we are able to work with people all over
the world
to develop you know
compelling content but that is
accessible or is made more accessible
because we cut it into shorter segments
or because we create these
um you know circling questions and
things of that nature so i'm doing a lot
of that kind of thing in persian i'm
doing the same kind of thing in arabic i
just received a uh segment from my
arabic collaborator who is in morocco
and today i switched to arabic
um i think that's uh
one thing yeah i mean
a lot of the same things that other
people do it's kind of what i do i do
i do uh review
but only when i'm turning the page
and in persian
uh typically
most of the time particularly on the
more difficult content i will be in
sentence mode all the time
so
for those of you who aren't familiar
with sentence mode
uh sentence mode is it's much easier
uh
to work in sentence mode you're getting
one sentence at a time
uh
in a lot of the languages you get a
translation
persian is a tough language to be in
because a lot of the normal services
aren't available
with no text to speech
translation is not although there should
be translation i don't know why there
isn't at any rate
use sentence mode is tremendously
powerful
um
and of course when i do uh
turn the page
uh got it okay when i do turn the page
i'm mostly on my ipad
then i'll review when turning the page
but i won't go at you know thousands of
words that i have to review them because
it's it's simply too time consuming and
and i do have this impression that when
we review
in fact you know what maybe i'll just
unshare uh stops here
uh
you know there is this thing
there is this thing that um
you know we have the impression that
we're learning and yet you know it
evaporates so you can study our grammar
you know declension table
and you think you've learned something
and the next day it's gone
uh
so
the same with looking so with grammar
rules that's true with reviewing
vocabulary that's true so i tend just to
rely on the fact that if i continue
listening and reading gradually more and
more things will stick
and yeah and and certainly
uh
you know listening is so important it
creates momentum for everything it's a
core core activity
okay that's basically what i had to say
no any questions
okay i've found some questions here yeah
um
a question for you all i'm about to
learn russian and before using link i
want to start with asimil books what do
you think about them uh asimil is you
know it varies from language to language
i've done them in
i've looked at them or used them in four
or five languages russian is one of the
better ones
uh i use asimil primarily for the
content the content in the russian sml
is good it's amusing
as in all assimil books it ramps up very
quickly so for the first 20 or 30
lessons it's very easy and then all of a
sudden they really pick up speed
um it's content i i don't think you know
it has a great reputation but there are
a lot of features there that i don't
like uh they don't give you the
individual word meanings
they
you know you have to kind of flip back
and forth to the translation what i have
done in the past is uh for arabic and
persian
is to pay people to transcribe them so
that i can get them in the link
i i
you know it it's whatever you like i
mean it's it's more expensive like
assimil is three times the price of
teach yourself it's essentially the same
it's a beginner book with some content
and some grammar explanations not more
than that in my opinion
okay someone asked what are circling
questions can i answer that yeah sure
okay so if you have a story and in it it
says
uh
the link group had
a
webinar
which is a statement out of the story
so that's a statement so in your
questions you get the statement the link
group have a webinar then there's a
question
did the link group go to dinner
and then the answer is no the link group
didn't go to dinner they had a webinar
so you have three bytes there a
statement a question and an answer
most of the vocabulary and most of the
structures repeat except that it's in
question form in one of the three cases
so what this does is it gives you much
more repetition in the many stories
you're already getting
two versions of the same story in
different tents or different person and
then you add on these three circling
questions the questions are not about
testing your comprehension the questions
are simply more concentrated exposure to
vocabulary and structure those are
circular circling questions
someone else asks i think a bit of
german grammar is inevitable how else
can you work out
uh
indi
and in their course
well i can tell you you can look at the
declension table
you can think that you can remember it
and in my experience three days later
you've forgotten it
uh at some point
uh
it just beca personally like i gave up
on uh
trying to remember them i speak german
it comes out i don't know if it's indi
but at some point if you're with people
and you hear the correct version more
often it'll gradually stick it's the
same as genders in french where you get
used to hearing
uh you know
in gonda maison so it's it's feminine
because it's gone to me zone you get
used to these phrases
i find that and so
this level of
getting used to the language and getting
used to certain phrases and genders and
and case endings is a matter of a lot of
uh listening and reading so that the
brain eventually gets used to it it can
be aided by looking at the table at
times you're curious or you're trying to
remember what was that how did that work
again and very often the dictionaries
enable you you know you have conjugating
dictionaries and you got the clinching
tables and you can always go there but
ultimately
you have to get used to in my experience
through lots of listening and reading
and and probably like if you get it
wrong people will understand you and
so
you would like to speak perfectly but i
think we often say perfection is the
enemy of language learning
like
right and for example when you say
you're perfectly understandable
and if you get now to the point where
you have accumulated vocabulary and
someone said here that they were
studying i don't know whether it's
polish or german and their teacher was
very impressed with their vocabulary and
of course
this person i can't find the comment
credited link with that
if you build up your vocabulary to where
you can start speaking to people and
having meaningful conversations you're
going to tune in to how they're speaking
and you're going to tune in to them
using these words correctly so the more
you can speak the more you'll hear
people speaking correctly and the more
you will gradually adjust your own
use of the language to get it closer to
the way the native speaker is speaking
to try to go in and ace that
up front maybe some people can do that
i'm not capable of doing that and with
my german as it is
uh it was only when i stopped trying to
memorize these tables where i got into
more natural listening and reading that
my my german picked up i got you know i
understood more i enjoyed speaking more
i didn't worry about the declensions and
they gradually got better
and i i think beca if you do focus on
the declensions early it takes takes
time and that's all time that would be
better spent listening and reading i
think that's the point like you can
spend time trying to perfect a tiny bit
of german or you can expose yourself to
a massive amount of german and then
over time your your
accuracy will
get better and better but your your
length of time to
fluency or being able to speak and
understand will be much shorter if you
if you don't focus
so much on this bits and pieces
uh but it's but
expose yourself to the
massive amount of content that you need
to expose yourself to to
to help your brain learn
uh another question here uh is it's is
it important to maintain a streak as you
get more advanced sometimes gathering
new words every day seems to distract
from other areas that need attention
well i mean i think the streak is
motivating
but obviously
different people have different
circumstances so the street what we
count in the streak is a bit arbitrary
so uh but i find it motivating and i
would say that that the streak at least
the basic
level of the street the 13 links
even if you're advanced
uh 13 links
isn't that many and so even if you're
doing other things speaking
um
yeah i mean you you come across fewer
unknown words so it's
it's harder to make links but you're
able to read much faster so
you know it does drive you to do more
reading which you need to do to continue
to improve your language so
you know it's not just about creating
the 13 links in order to create the 13
links
it forces you to do all the other things
that are good for you
when i was
at my challenge where i was doing arabic
persian and turkish i was creating a
hundred links a day in each
and i didn't go to bed until i had
created a hundred in each okay i
eventually gave up my turkish and i'm no
longer doing that but i think it got me
into it like it's it's just an
obligation it's a it's a stick it's a
stick it works
um
there's a question here about
interference when learning languages so
someone's learning spanish and want to
start learning french how to avoid
interviewing interference of the two
languages
well i don't know i have learned related
languages obviously slavic languages
romance languages
there is even you know crossover
vocabulary between arabic and persian
um
it can be
confusing at first but as you get
further and further into whichever
language it is
you get less interference
so
as long as you understand as long as
you're communicating you're doing fine
and if you were to focus for whatever
reason they say you're doing italian and
spanish and then you go off to spain or
italy
then you'll focus in on that language
but if when you switch from one to
another there's interference i don't see
that as a big problem
uh someone
where did that go sorry
someone says please don't get rid of the
classic version
uh
we have no plans to get rid of the
classic version uh there are fewer and
fewer people using it but we hope with
our new version we'll actually give you
reasons to
switch over to the new version so
um
but yeah we aren't going to remove the
classic version
uh someone else says
touche palo visage good advice
good advice in these times
so hard though i know
uh do you think only reading could
improve your speaking skills someone
asks
it you know reading and listening
especially listening builds up your
potential for speaking
the reading typically is better for
acquiring vocabulary i mean they have to
be done together but the listing gets
the language sort of playing in your
brain and gets you to where you can
start speaking but you can't become a
good speaker of the language without
speaking so there comes a point where
you have to start speaking and
eventually speaking a lot if at that
time you have good comprehension skills
and a good vocabulary your speaking
skills will improve
quickly so you do also have to speak
okay someone says what's the word count
to get into the intermediate stage for
languages like spanish and french so we
have some targets in mind
uh first of all with regard to word
count if you are
looking at the progress
widget on link
uh
you can
i guess you can you can see
[Music]
every every three months basically we
are suggesting that you're moving up a
level
so that if you look at the next if
you're
if you're a completely complete beginner
and you look at your three month targets
those are the known words targets that
we
set
for you to achieve beginner two
and six months out
those targets show you what you the
known words
level that you need to achieve to reach
intermediate one and so on so every
three months if you set
that if you set the the time period on
your your statistics widget it'll show
you the known words targets for the next
for for for
yeah every at any rate every three
months is another level so that could
give you some idea but maybe steve you
can talk about it a little more yeah i
mean obviously anything that we say is
going to be a little bit arbitrary
and
depends on the language obviously if
you're going into spanish from english
theoretically you have about 50 of the
vocabulary which is more or less
recognizable
uh because of the common roots
i tend to
you know i see the known words total as
proof that i'm improving
okay i have three thousand words five
thousand words i've got eleven thousand
words in arabic 4 000 words in persian
all i know is i'm getting more and more
known words i i don't really put any
sort of objective value on that what to
me is the biggest indicator is i bring
in a podcast
in arabic or persian that's been
transcribed this is real authentic
content
three months ago there were thirty
percent unknown words and now there's
fifteen percent unknown i look at my
page it's largely white some blue some
yellow so
i i find that this is the thing test
yourself bring something in from a
newspaper bring something in that's
easier see how many new words there are
there for you and and i'm motivated by
seeing you know i'm continuously you
know
happily surprised to see that there's
just more and more white on my lesson
page so i'm guided more by that than
some you know
probably quite arbitrary number as to
what my
um you know known words total should be
in order to be able to read a newspaper
grab a newspaper article see how many
unknown words there are
could i there's one here too i've been a
person who wants to improve their
english do you have any suggestions for
improving my fluency and speaking with
proper chinese grammar
i mean
i think we first of all i am not
as someone who has learned chinese i
don't know a single chinese grammar term
uh chinese has a very
practical approach to grammar words
don't change word order is flexible
you pick up on how people speak and you
try to imitate how they speak and that's
it so i have no suggestions other than
to continue a lot of listening and
reading and speak every opportunity you
get
and and one other question here about
the value of esperanto as a lead-in to
other languages
the advantage of esperanto is that it's
easy to learn
and i think particularly with children
it gives them the sense that they can
learn languages so it might encourage
them to learn other languages
ultimately though
you want to focus on learning the
language you're interested in so if you
are interested in esperanto learn it for
that reason if you are actually
interested in learning french then i
would put all of my efforts into
learning french and not spend however
many months are necessary to learn
esperanto first that's what i would do
okay
uh
i had a
question here
uh someone's asking
about taiwanese or mandarin with
traditional characters we do have that
available so i'm not sure if you're
having problems downloading lessons um
maybe reach out to support because that
you shouldn't be it should be working
fine
i have some questions here uh
mark one is a person who was have you
seen that a person raised in finland
raising from pakistan
you know who's working to improve his
english
has a still child level of finish what
can you do well it's the same it makes
no difference basically we're all in the
same position we start either at a zero
level or a child level or you know
intermediate level and it's just more
listening and reading
very much
the way link is structured
uh
specific requirements for promoting a
beta language to fully supported
language what is it mark 60 mini stories
60 mini story well we essentially 60
mini stories we launch the language but
we don't really have a
fixed level anymore on what uh moves the
language from beta to
fully supported but it
needs a significant amount of content so
60 mini stories launches the language as
a beta language
but you know most of those
less popular languages
are likely not to come out of beta on
unless we get a volunteer member who
really
is able to generate or find or or source
upload a lot of content to the point
where
it makes sense
um
to move its status to support it but
fundamentally there isn't much
difference between beta and supported
languages other than of course volume of
content everything else is is
essentially the same
um
oh sorry
yes
i was just going to say someone again
this question
has come up so i'll answer it again does
copyright affect adding to link and the
answer is no if you're
importing it just for yourself
copyright's not a factor you can import
anything
um as long as you're not sharing it and
and you have to
deliberately share it so not to worry
about copyright
uh another question how do you balance
time spent actually reading versus time
spent looking up words i feel like i
spend my time looking up words and not
following the story so much
as far as
from my perspective i mean
the more unknown words there are the
more chopped up your reading is but uh
that's why it's important to try and
find content that doesn't have too high
a percentage of unknown words
at the same time even if if you are
interested in
more difficult content and you
study it
and it's slow progress at first
uh you know after
you know a month
you'll be amazed at how much faster your
progress is so you can't stay with it if
it's difficult or you can try to find
content with fewer unknown words and
again you're trying to
it's chopped up if you're it's it's not
as as nice as reading in your native
language but you get better and better
and better and you just have to
persevere and the time spent looking up
words is not wasted time you're you're
you're spending time with that word all
of which helps
um
to eventually
uh make it stick in your in your mind
uh i should add too that um the
advantage of the mini stories is that
the vocabulary repeats five times
so in the
first version of the story you're
looking up a lot of words
that same story is told in a different
tense or different person it'll have
much fewer new words and when the
questions are asked again there'll be
very few new words so the many stories
there's a good three months of content
if you're starting in
and from there
look for content that has fewer new
words in it that's obviously makes the
journey easier
someone else asks how to submit writing
through the mobile app you cannot submit
writing through the mobile app you can
only do it on the website either
on the exchange for free or you can
actually submit pay to submit writing
and have it corrected by a tutor
but that's again only on the website
i see a question here about ukrainian
content
uh
of course we have a fair amount of
content for ukrainian uh in our library
but and i haven't looked for ukrainian
content uh uh in youtube
but i would imagine there's quite a bit
there
again i had to search i have things that
i
found in ukrainian but i can't share
uh audiobooks ebooks
uh i'm sure there are movies it's just a
matter of looking for it and then using
the chrome or the whatever browser
extension to import it into link
someone says should i read a book in my
own language
and then
translate it into my target language in
order to learn more vocabulary or just
in the target language
uh i mean
i would say read it in the target
language
uh if you
it depends on your level
i know that when i started i read harry
potter in japanese so when i started
i needed the english
version in order to understand what was
being said
but probably about a third of the way
through the book i stopped using the
english version because
my comprehension still wasn't perfect
but it was good enough and it just
delayed me more to read the english
version
i had never read the english version
otherwise so so for me
definitely at the beginning i needed
that
english version to understand but
as soon as i could get away with not
using it i prefer to just stay with
the japanese
but again it's
up to you i mean depends how perfectly
you need to understand it but i i found
reading and listening and reviewing the
words and kind of listening many times i
was able to understand
well enough
uh in in the target language only i
don't know
what others feel
yeah i agree with you and we shouldn't
obsess with understanding everything and
even if we understand it imperfectly
that's okay it's all exposure the brain
is getting used to the language
um
yeah someone else asks about the streak
again uh
again this idea that i don't want to
create links every day because some days
i just want to review and
yes to some and we talk about this stuff
internally as well because we we want
the streak to work for everybody
um but in the end we keep coming back to
the fact that actually creating 13 links
it shouldn't take that long so
if that if you've a and and and people
have a bit of a tendency to want to
create some links and then review them
until they know them before creating new
ones and and we do not want you to do
that
we want you creating way more links than
you can possibly review because actually
that's the fastest way
uh to grow your vocabulary create links
read more
you'll see those words again if they
matter
don't obsess too much about going back
over stuff although you should re-read
previous lessons and click on your
yellow words
um but that that that idea that you know
what spend 10 15 minutes create those 13
links and then go review or do other
things but make sure every day you're
pushing your level forward so that
you'll achieve your goals faster
i don't know if anyone has any other
questions sees any others or or you know
we've been going for for a while now
um maybe it's it's uh
one thing i want to say mark oh sure
yeah yeah uh this is the first of these
sessions we don't always have to go
quite this long but we would also like
to have other people participate
this time it was the link team we would
like to have other people especially
link users come on and talk about what
they do how they use the site so if you
want to apply
uh either you know send me a note on the
youtube channel or send a note to link
or
uh where would you recommend that they
uh
basically let us know if they want to
participate yeah uh there's a there's a
forum thread uh for this uh event so you
can post there i mean any anywhere
anywhere you can uh
you you can find a post we'll see it and
um
yeah hopefully we get we can get a
panel of link users together and and
with steve uh next time around and we'll
try to do this i guess every week while
we're kind of in our
lock down period
one thing i wanted to add to
you know because so many people are
locked down
it's very important to do two things i
think to one to have a disciplined
approach to your day and to engage in
some meaningful
activity on a regular basis it's going
to carry us through and the second thing
to connect
so here we hope to achieve both those
things to encourage you and to encourage
each other
in our
very positive constructive activity of
language learning and at the same time
to connect
so that's the purpose of these sessions
and hopefully we can have some different
faces on the panel next week
okay sounds good thank you very much for
joining us thanks guys thanks everyone
bye bye bye